you ready to go hey everybody welcome to
episode 325 of the askgaryvee show and
I'm very excited about this episode
let's go right into it I know a lot of
people are watching on live stream
across all the platforms but it's going
to be LinkedIn today as we continue
testing out LinkedIn live LinkedIn
please put in your phone numbers if you
have a question for my distinguished
guest here today mark him and allow you
to introduce yourself in a second new
book is out obviously I'm really excited
about talking about Netflix and his
career but I want to get into a bunch of
questions because even in the first
three four minutes of just hanging with
him before we went live I think the
energy is gonna be really good which is
exciting to me from a Content standpoint
so mark why don't you introduce yourself
and tell everybody a little bit about
your origin story sounds good Gary so
mark Randolph co-founder for CEO Netflix
and now soon-to-be author which is kind
of adding something totally new to my
mix so for you
origins story well I'm 61 so I'm still
working out what my origin story is like
well where were you born I was born just
yes so unless I'm a New York boy yes I
was for the first half of my life and so
what kind of kid were you so I was a kid
who anytime I wanted to do something my
parents said we'll go for it
that's all I come home and go dad I'm
gonna go caving and rather than being
like what are you what are you nuts
I'd get the fantastic that sounds really
cool that's really neat it was really
neat where were you in the queue you
only child you have siblings oh I'm the
oldest of three okay
so right off the bat even you know it's
funny you hear that a lot more from a
third child's perspective then so even
as the oldest your parents had gave you
some room yeah I think for a third child
it's like what's what's your name yep no
it was really great and it other thing I
cut I do reflect back on what was it
about how I grew up that maybe gave me
some of the things we have and but one
is that it was also a family where no is
always just something to get around it
was like not something that you took no
and walked away and left from the
standpoint of if your parents said no
they appreciated you try
to figure it out a little bit because my
mom was like that a little bit yeah and
also them kind of recognizing that when
her barrier came up it wasn't like we
give up and walk away okay it was always
being said there's yeah amazing go go
right into it a little bit later this is
what I was I was graduating from college
okay and I wanted to get a job as a
advertising exec okay I was really into
I get it so anyway I applied for this
job at NW Ayer okay no one are here but
big firm yep and it was one of those
jobs which only usually goes to MBAs yep
this is an undergraduate so as a
longshot thing and those like I don't
know a thousand people applying and I
got through the first round and then the
second round they bring you to New York
and I got the second round in the third
round they bring you back and I got down
to the point where there was only four
people applying for this job Wow and it
was like this holy [ __ ] and I went in
and interviewed with everybody whole day
and didn't get it and went slinking back
up to upstate New York to college and
that going well screw it I'm I'm not
gonna give up so I wrote these long
emails to our letters letters letters to
everybody and basically was saying like
all right you found I'll try again what
could I do better what should I learn
what do you want to see and then the guy
goes come on down and brings me up and
offers me the job and the crazy thing is
that no one was given the job none of
the four of us interested that this was
a job which was about turning a no into
a yes and so they said no to everybody
and waited to see who would not take no
for an answer
really absolutely that's amazing that a
crazy crazy thing I love it yeah and so
that really is probably the best
articulation of how I grew up
interesting so you took that job no I
kind of actually notice how I just set
that up I kind of the way you were
telling us wrong I'm like he didn't take
the [ __ ] shop I did I took an even
crazier job which was there was a guy
I'm huh this is a cravat even told this
story before there was a guy in Memphis
Tennessee oh and a big cotton company
sold it in the family for 200 years made
a gazillion dollars okay and was
basically driving around throwing money
out the window basically feels like
today
and he bought these properties and I'm
kind of an outdoorsy guy
okay I've always been into like your
story was caves yes absolutely I was
like whoa this guy had bought a ski shop
he had bought a place out in Vail and he
was looking for someone to tie them all
together and he goes you're gonna run
you're gonna run this kind of this big
Co marketing business did you know who
their family friends because there's no
way that somebody like that would give
you that at bad at that young of an age
unless there was some other variable
relationship I carry or drag me down of
these complicated stories but I'm not
your programmer so there's a
organization that and I apologize in
this where I want to bring value to the
audience mark here's why the reason I'm
probing is that because I have a very
good sense of my audience and ironically
I'm pretty good at this other than in
fact I love to interrupt all the time
because I'm just because I already know
what the answers are and because I'm
usually on a time crunch so they
actually the audience gets mad at me
because I interrupt everyone on the flip
side I have an incredible sense of what
stories could bring value I promise you
mark let me tell you one thing about
this audience this is not the Today Show
like what's amazing about this audience
is 34 people arbitrary number just heard
that story and literally in the next 24
hours are gonna reply to a no and one of
them's gonna get a yes and you and I
literally right now just change the
course of somebody's life and that's
what gets me high it's it's unbeliev I'm
by the way don't about the interrupting
I mean if you had just said like past
the roles
yeah methought I was yeah I love it so
tell me about the story the member was
cool how'd you get to him so when I was
14 they packed my parents packed me off
to Wyoming to do this backpacking trip
in the mountains and it turns haulage
eyes again which one of your parents was
super outdoorsy if either my dad okay my
dad grew up in Austria so he kind of
interesting all keep going so and then I
I loved this program and it was a
program of teaches leadership using a
wilderness as a setting and I was a
student there for three or four summers
and then I ended up teaching there as a
leader and then eventually got hooked
when I was leading leading the whole
courses so a lot of responsibility young
that was my college summer job and so
this Julian J hohenberg the third the
guy with the cotton company that one of
the things he did when he was throwing
the money out the window was I'm gonna
take a
he went out to Wyoming he did this
course you taught it I did not okay
he was so enamored by the course and the
instructors that when he heard from my
through someone else that I was in his
drug course leader there he goes I want
that guy you know what's so funny I to
this day still have that in me you show
me a kid a guy or a gal who flips
sneakers cells blow pops does cards like
I believe in that [ __ ] you know what the
genetic marker is for entrepreneurship
I do not it's candy arbitrage everyone
almost everyone I meet like you said
it's the same thing it's going in and
buying it for 10 cents in the next day
you go to school for a buck and if you
show me anybody that it's why I love
people that sell weed who so like if you
tell me that you sold weed from a bad
neighborhood obviously normally but not
always and you sold Nickelback's I
already am interested in you because it
means you literally arbitrage dime bags
but this is somebody who's never smoked
weed telling this story but now I to
college taught me but I always thought
my friend Rob muse would have been a
good entrepreneur because he had the
discipline and the grind to go down to
the nickel bag level that takes a real
[ __ ] commitment and so arbitrage in
any way absolutely right it said that
it's the vision to go I'm not gonna it's
seeing an opportunity it's seeing a
pressure differential a hundred percent
and that happens for kids who are six
when it's candy it happens for people
under 26 or 46 when I see oh man
taxis suck you know I'm gonna do a
hundred thousand percent it's it's
that's why it's such a marker for that
it's someone who sees meringues early
matched of course with all these other
things of course you've seen which is
this so that's what happened you're a
kid at a school you're 22 yeah and
you're now running this conglomerate of
different businesses and then even worse
I did this job or six matter and this
company had better the company that one
of the properties was in in the kind of
ghost town and resort in outside a veil
okay and the manager left and they go
and I go I want that job and so they
moved me out and now you know this 23
year old owes no knows nothing and he's
running this place which has 60
employees and has these huge cash flow
issues
and a restaurant and a bar and and and
then I'm going down I'm doing the
marketing and the advertising and it was
like cash flow 101
it was management 101 it was thrown into
this super deep pool and going to swim
oh I'm sitting here quiet because I'm
like oh my god we grew up the same way
by the way I'm the byproduct of the same
thing in a liquor store yeah it was a
small base of like four or five six
employees and then I grew it but by the
time I was 25 years old I had managed
people I'd paid all my bills with my cat
own cash flow you no credit no credit
line I forget about [ __ ] raising
capital no credit line the first
business I built from three to sixty
million dollars a year in [ __ ] eight
years had no credit that's awesome
because then you don't see credit as a
crutch you see it as a it's a thing to
use but you know now how to use that the
otherwise it's awesome and even if
you're trained in it when I raised money
for empathy I didn't spend it as well
yeah when when you know like that's
exactly right it is something that could
say if you overspend you're out of
business and that is a very very strict
teacher so I mean yeah you did that
these are cool things some stuff did
that and then it got probably the the
job which influenced me the most is I I
got this weird job quick quick question
I think a lot of people struggle with so
you're 23 and you're in this resort town
right yeah ski resort town it's sort of
it's halfway between Vail and steamboat
which means the middle of nowhere got it
but it's close to both and you're 23 23
and you've got this kind of cool big job
yep how did you balance your personal
life and your professional life at that
point in your life because I'm actually
I'm not gonna even lead the question
what did you do how much did you date
how much fun were you having how much
not fun were you having that's a great
thing it was it was a really good lesson
I had a lot of fun so don't get me wrong
because everyone was working there was
23 yeah and so and it was you were the
Alpha of the 23 and that was leverage
that was the bad part though was that
these guys we're it was on the banks of
the Colorado River so they'd all go hey
we're all going
rafting now I'm going I've got to do you
know inventory or I got to pay you know
I add these responsibilities and it kind
of really was painful so I got a lot of
funds I'm not moaning it but there was
this realization that there's a
different level of responsibility that I
had but I did meet my wife there and so
something amazing did come out of
awesome come out of that go ahead
all right so come back to East and got
this how old must have been only 24 so
you're there quick 25 two years in
Colorado two and a half years okay keep
going
so um come back and get this crazy job
basically as a gopher to the CEO of a
music publishing company I think my
title was like chief of staff looking at
all these guys is like literally mine so
far I just want everybody who's
listening to me right now I'm sorry mark
I'm taking over everyone who's listening
I just I don't know if you've been
listening but I think I could see some
of you in the room putting the pieces
together my court my court advise is to
do and like manage and like like
actually make and sell like that and and
then or and or if you want to be
somebody go work as an admin a gopher a
chief of staff for somebody that's
extremely at a very high level each [ __ ]
is basically what I'm saying basically
is what I'm saying
and I'm just gonna make it simple here
so far what I've heard from mark is the
first two things he's in his career was
jumped in full throttle sacrifice is
what he was saying
couldn't have as much fun dealt with all
that was practical and then and then had
the humility let's say one more time for
all the people out there that love being
a CEO had the humility to go from being
the lead dog of something like that you
know in that ecosystem to then going and
being a gopher
a chief of staff of whatever ever about
to here and I just want to remind all of
you this all led for him to be the
co-founder and CEO of Netflix so it's
I'm so glad you called a little segment
timeout on that one because that
is the piece of ice I give to every
single person who goes I want to come
out looking fine I want to be an
entrepreneur what should I do and the
answer is really simple you find the
smartest person who will take you
seriously
and do anything they ask the end that's
it and just gave you to the Sun
absolutely right watch and I got this
job you're shaking your head right
because think about it it's [ __ ] the
game it's it's such a simple thing and
people get all hung up on their ego and
they they got was insecure I have a I
have a degree in this is it's crazy it's
just you got to do stuff and you and you
got to see how people who know how to do
it do it and it's the combination of
those two things and I was a music
publishing company so it had rights you
know published sheet music books
administered music rights that kind of
stuff the guy's name the guy's name
guy's name was Lauren Kaiser believe it
or not but old-school dude yeah a little
bit but you know I thought my job was
what was he rough yeah absolutely he was
kind of a street guy uh-huh but here cuz
he's in music you know but he he was
give me one ridiculous story from that
he like liked what he liked give me
something ridiculous to happen in the
first six months that you were there so
you get there or a little bit Colorado
chill now yeah into the East Coast speed
it was from the street pretty intense
because it it was lots of yelling that's
what that's right that was that was the
hard part about it I mean you saw how
this guy treated people at all at all
different levels yeah like he was you
see how you dealt with this person or
the talent who came in he wasn't he was
nice to them and it was like a real
disconnect he was yes and it was kind of
a weird thing right exactly kind of
really form this thing I mean there's
there's a
guy Oh God this is a good one I haven't
told this story either so these are good
so this guy was the production manager
okay who's the guy who's in charge of
getting the books out on time yes
unbelievable [ __ ] I mean seriously
yeah and one this is a true story one
time when someone was about called up
and said we're gonna miss my deadline he
goes you're not gonna miss the deadline
and he go and he and they sent them a
little package and it had a razor blade
a rubber band and a Dixie cup and he
sent it to them and said if this is late
I want your balls in that Cup like I'm
going oh my god but this weird thing is
everyone like this guy like every
morning hey Frank
freakin Frank and so I'm going what is
wrong with me
why do I hate this guy why can I not
stand this guy and everyone else seems
to like him and then of course what
happens is he gets fired and as soon as
he's gone Oh an [ __ ] it was and that
was another huge revelation for me of
seeing like all of realizing that my
judgment is okay I understand that if I
think someone's and how long did you do
that job not long because what happened
is like the culture no I stay at the
company but part of it was working
around that he had all these different
businesses and one of them was a
mail-order division now we're getting
into the big intersection between you
and me and here's this picture God 1985
or six and it's so but the mailer
division is in the back of all the song
books is a little line of type it says
for a list of more great Cherry Lane
song books send a self-addressed stamped
envelope to and my job which was and I
said for god knows why I want that job I
told him because you could have autonomy
yes and and then so my job at first was
I just want to remind everybody we're
really getting meta here there's a
reason why now that I understand marks
framework you could see how easy that
like that was I'm sure a lot of people
watching and literally
like how do you know that I know that
because once I understand somebody's
framework to the world which we clearly
have a very similar one it's very easy
for me to understand that and it's also
where all the opportunity is right now
if you're working somewhere what's great
about entrepreneurship is its autonomy
what's great about being an executive
who has deep entrepreneurial tendencies
but for whatever reason is currently not
an entrepreneur is the ability to see
the arbitrage where there is autonomy
usually where nobody's paying attention
to yeah usually where there's no money
yet if you wait'll it's obvious it's too
late so that's part of it so um anyway
this I mean this that's not that I went
into this business which is xeroxing the
list of more great trailing slowing
books and sticking it in the
self-addressed stamped envelope and then
going to the warehouse and filling the
orders why do you think you had so much
humility to take on these jobs like go
deep with me like not surface-level why
intuitively deeply do you think you had
the ability to have humility because I
believe humility has been my deepest
advantage on the market it's not the one
that's obvious I don't really care what
people think of me but I think that's
that's looking back I think at for the
first 10 years I didn't even realize
that was it I didn't really care people
thought of me and so I was following my
intellectual curiosity without going
through the filter of how will this look
or yeah you know what I mean so it's
it's a I think that's part of it and and
this is fascinating for some weird
reason intuitive direct like there's
something here direct marketing yeah you
know all of a sudden would do color
lists of satsang books with photos and
now it's a brochure and then it's a
catalog I need did you love the feedback
oh my goodness was that feedback loop
connection unbelievable because that's
what it was for me at first when I think
back to marketing sure what if I do this
what will happen it was almost
scientific and avoiding all the all the
argument oh no it should be read no I
should be blue full autonomy no for sure
or no in fact or at is 0.27 four percent
better than blue but you knew that after
the fact yes of course that's the
beautiful thing of it well that's having
humility to being okay with being wrong
yeah there's like the other
day I posted a book Instagram post
upside down the video is upside down it
did not do well I could i [ __ ] him so
happy you don't even know I thought the
size I wanted it to do well but nothing
gets me more excited than when the
market says to me hey tough guy you
think you're so [ __ ] good after 25
years eat this dick I love that I love
when the market does that to me it'll be
upsetting if all of a sudden they didn't
really got the same response upside down
it's right side up I would really say
something but to me it's like breaking
behavior right yeah how do you break
through so anyway nonetheless okay so I
direct marketing so it turns into that I
just built this thing up into like a
mail-order division like really pretty
substantial real then the next big break
was this music company goes who wants
her in a magazine we're gonna start a
guitar magazine with sheet music in it
and they're all clamoring for the
editorial positions because everyone
there is into music and they're going
who's gonna do the circulation and it's
like one of those everyone take one step
taking one step forward and they all
step backwards and it's like I'm going I
don't I don't know how to do magazine's
circulation and I learned caught myself
magazine circulation which is
subscriptions subscription marketing how
that whole business works launch the
magazine called guitar yeah yep pretty
big pretty good one yeah successful then
I got recruited away from there to help
start a computer mac computer magazine
called Mac user went to Mac user and
again doing them doing all the
circulation work we sold Mac user to
Ziff Davis launched a mail-order company
I want this one now each time I'm
getting more and more toward being the
alpha of these things then I they put me
in charge of launching a mail-order
company called Mac warehouse and micro
warehouse big male water company yeah
and that went public but for then I got
the next big break which is ended up
getting hired to turn around a male at
our company in Carmel California off my
wife and I go to Carmel assuming it's an
expat
type assignment in other words I'm an
East Coast boy like you know and you get
to California to going this isn't so bad
every time especially Carmel and so we
sold I turned the company around we sold
it to a company back here my wife and I
are looking at each other and going like
I'm not sure we want to go back to there
okay and this thing is in Carmel which
is right on the coast but it's kind of
south there's nothing around it so
there's no job sell no jobs
west-east rather certainly no jobs west
the oceans there so it's gone or 'the
young man and i ended up getting a job
at a company called Borland
international to stay with us philippe
con guy that i mentioned earlier was CEO
and this was old fashioned software
everything was sold in a computer store
all retail go downloads obviously no
mail order remember and I saw the
arbitrage I go this is nuts
I knew all this stuff about mail order I
knew catalogs I knew how this was gonna
direct mail I'd mailed gazillion pieces
of Direct Mail getting these magazines
launched and I go this is crazy
and convinced them to hire me to do the
direct marketing and that took me longer
I was at Borland almost seven years but
it took me four years to bring that to
almost 40 45 percent of all their sales
was direct sales huge huge thing buried
the earth ok foot deep in mail letter P
mail order pieces for software but
unbelievable but that was the next
transition is the theme of all this is
it's like falling uphill they needed
someone to run one of their software
divisions not I was in this marketing
group because I was worried sales and
they go can you run this as a general
manager and that put me into the really
into the tech business because then I
had you know in programmers working for
me and I had the full responsibility for
bringing out a product yes and that was
the transition into being much more into
general management in the tech business
learning how software was made learning
all those pieces yes
we sold off my division and then ended
up we're almost here ended up we sold
off that division and I went to work for
a small start-up called Visionnaire
which made scanners which was the most
dysfunctional place even more than the
music publishing place the most
dysfunctional place because the
symbiotes everything stems from the top
it does he was like you could have a two
person company that's dysfunctional this
year he's an idiot it just wouldn't make
a decision it didn't let people have
fight fiefdom and fight with each other
it was the only job my wife has since
said that she could tell I did not want
to go to work in the morning interesting
so we're about a year about 15 months
and I got fired so second time my life
have been fired which they did you a
huge [ __ ] favor yeah absolutely
you're telling me and then I got to work
I overcompensated and went to work for
two very good friends of mine starting a
small software company that and I say
overcompensated because it was great
working for my friends it was a really
geeky software company was making tools
for Quality Assurance engineers at that
point after that 15 month experience it
was nice to go somewhere safe oh my god
absolutely I had to be with people I
liked and enjoy the other thing there
was a marketing person I kind of have
always wanted to understand and like my
product and I didn't really I couldn't
empathize that well with people who did
Quality Assurance but you teach yourself
hi the great gift of my life as I've
never sold anything I don't believe in
yeah it's it I just refused to I'm not
good at it that's that's the thing and
if you're not gonna suck at selling
that's it then I totally agree with you
that's really cool so anyway that's what
led because that little software company
that I had was with these two other guys
starting we had 12 people and we got
sold to a big software company called
pure atria which was a company which had
been founded and was being run by a
gentleman named Reed Hastings
that was a good transaction for you miss
absolutely right cuz those guys all got
banished to the basement to be a
business unit I was put in
as a head of marketing because he needed
a marketing person so I'll begin working
directly for Reid
this was 1996 or 1995 and thus became
the relationship that yes and luckily
not just like working for Reid Reid and
I found out we lived in the same town
and so we began commuting to work every
day
Wow and form this friendship and then
the real break was that six to nine
months later pure atria was acquired and
unlike the last transition which was
great you know Guster's all made money
and we all got keep jobs this one the
investors made money but Reid and I were
gonna get fired or I understand made
redundant I understand as this
expression goes and I said awesome I'm
gonna start a company ready yeah
and how old are you 38 37 38 something
I'm bad you ready oh I was ready and I'd
kind of had these responsibilities of
starting companies but we did a
framework yep and I knew what I wanted
to do because I had all this 20 years of
direct marketing experience I had
circular subscription I I knew a lot of
these pieces and I saw in the internet
that this was direct response on
steroids
this was catalog done to a level that no
one could imagine doing cap yet when I
when I launched my hybrid calm in 96 the
entire wine business at the highest
level the KL is the zacky's the Shari
Lehman's who I aspire to defeat their
entire infrastructure was on catalog and
I remember vividly the first time I saw
the Internet in 94 and I was like I've
got absolutely and every new every month
they miss the boat you're going like and
they miss the pub on the way they did it
yeah right people hold on it's happening
right now it's why half my audience is
not going on tik-tok right now because
they made it on Instagram or YouTube
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's a that's
it we should talk about that later it's
a big dynamic about people are wanting
to lock into what they the past
being unwilling to transition to the
future it's the be guilty it's this the
single it's at when it's all said and
done it's one of the biggest ingredients
to why you and I have had professional
success
I do not demonize the future and we do
not put the past on a pedestal and we're
willing to walk away from the past no
matter how good and comfortable the past
I'll spit on the [ __ ] not only will I
spit on the past I'll spit on the past
that did right by me yes I build wine
library on the back of email marketing
on the back of Direct Mail on the back
of print on the back of radio it was
later that social emerged I will [ __ ] on
social one day yep I only care about the
consumer and whatever she or he is doing
is my religion there is nothing else you
know it is so funny because you put us
in the same category you and I see this
so clearly and we can't even tell people
here's how it works
it's my friend is hard it's built on
self-esteem and humility yeah we see it
yeah weird here's why whenever our
timing has been off has been when we
micro failed our game our game is pretty
key and timing yeah you know when you
see it like you have to get your timing
right yeah yeah right
I'm a better executive today than the 21
year old version of me yeah cuz I
understand timing better yeah yeah
that's right right right right and you
see more patterns you're getting better
at all those things right yeah that's
cool but so so but because we've had
micro failures because we got we were
there too early because it's never too
late yeah we've been there because we
don't we don't put that on a pedestal we
can only be too early right right right
right yeah absolutely so so you can't be
too early but you yeah correct right so
we are only vulnerable to that and thus
when we've micro failed it's been
predicated on that thus we had to be
able to deal with judgment right right
right right right the reason people like
the past is cuz it's safe
nobody gets fired for this whatever yeah
well said let's get to this part okay my
entire ecosystem around me is stress cuz
I'm super behind
okay so actually this was actually feet
that we need to talk about Netflix for a
second like so what and so you're right
on the cusp I can't like pull the rug
out well no it's actually a fantastic
intro because what we've done is led
this right up to where the book picks up
yeah
which is where Reid and I are in the car
driving back and forth in this period
we're waiting for the deal to close
nothing really to do and going what next
and you're brainstorming and we're
brainstorming because I'm going I'm
starting this company reads nod he's
gonna go off and be in he's gonna go off
and reform education but he wants in and
so he begins he says all vacuum and I'll
be on the board go off and do this and
but we need the idea and that really is
where that will never work kicks off is
us brainstorming idea and stupid ideas
you know everything personalized
baseball bats and customized dog food of
course shampoo delivery this model of
delivering it and Internet and
delivering it physical and
personalization personal which is my
other big theme so we were looking since
a degree and then you know it's this
crazy not like Jeff Bezos has this weird
idea about selling books books and so
we're going what are the other big
categories and video is an eight billion
video video sales eight billion category
but I go Bezos is gonna take that were
you were you the CEO when blockbuster
passed I'm buying Netflix or no no that
was after yeah that's back when we were
really not running the company together
understood I love [ __ ] like that like I
love that I don't know if you know this
I don't know if you know that yahoo
bought both Google and Facebook and both
deals died really really I did not know
that so I always think about the
what-ifs yeah yeah having a great I was
thinking that should be one of those
special interactive TV specials where
you can can hit this button and you can
see what happens if blockbuster did did
buy us do you know that that is my dream
of what happen is my [ __ ] dream of
heaven is being able to see scenarios
play out that didn't yeah the reason I'm
never scared to make a decision is I
know you'll never know the alternative
right right right right
yeah so to me my Nirvana mindset of what
heaven could be is the idea of going to
heaven and then be like this is the one
that I always think about
so I'd be like okay having a machine
like I sit down like [ __ ] I'm so pissed
I died
all right [ __ ] literally how I
picture I'm like alright [ __ ] it let me
start enjoying the new thing [ __ ] it
it's over
I died alright so I would say already
having first question
show me the draft pick that the Jets
should have taken that would have led
him to actually winning a Super Bowl
Yeah right play out the biggest one for
me that I always think about heaven show
me when I would have died from a
horrific accident had I not done
something weird like went back and
forgot my keys yeah yes threw off the
timing and the tree would have fell on
me or when I when I took that flight and
had I stayed here I would have choked on
that bone at dinner like I don't think
people understand this is what
fascinates me about decision making
people think it's binary right they're
like ah which job or university or what
start like you're not gonna make that
big of a difference yeah it yeah it's
just one little one little choice it's
not gonna set your whole life path it's
not you you have control of those I talk
about it all the time yeah so that's
what this books about so this book is
about two things it's the untold story
it's it's it kind of reveals that it's
we're just I don't know this at all
where are you were in Reid's
relationship right now great awesome
really good still socialized together we
and let me talk all the time I mean it's
a we had a result because I would have a
lot of empathy to write this book in the
white heat moment of Netflix right now
and it's still like we're still right in
the epicenter I'm actually genuinely
cured it's almost be like if my brother
right now wrote the book of vaynermedia
like we're still in it
yeah I always think it's a lot easier to
talk about [ __ ] when it's over good so I
guess my real question is was there
anything you wrote in there that you
like were like oh man I hope Reid is
okay with me saying this did you have
him read it like I actually am very
curious about how you write this book
right now both both of those both of
those things which is I said to myself I
have to be honest and vulnerable here
yes about myself because there's a lot
of stuff that I didn't do well a lot of
things I made mistakes course because
the whole point of the book is is to
show that someone can make a dream come
true
but it's really to say how so that
someone else can see these things and
I I think I could do that not start a
company not become but take any idea
they have and execute and execute that's
what I wanted and to do that I have to
show that I'm not superhuman I can't I
don't make them miraculously always the
right decisions that's an approach so
with so with I did the same thing with
Reid he is a real person not this super
CEO and I love it what did you on them
did you go up did you do did you go up
front and say hey I'm thinking about
writing this book and if I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna be super transparent about it
and thus I'm gonna talk about my
shortcomings but are you okay with me
going there because he's still in it yes
we talked a bunch about it it was one
moment I mean I think about I apologize
but I think about my brother coming to
me and I was like I want to write this
book and I'm like cool like where am i
where my body goes like bro can't you
just wait because because while I'm
still in it you're you're [ __ ] with
it while I'm in it whereas when it's
over it's I mean I've been able to share
so much more about Wine Library
since I'm out of it then I mean there's
so much I still want to share about to
my audience that I can't just yet
because if I do it [ __ ] me up because
I'm actively [ __ ] driving this boat
still right now absolutely true and I it
took distance I could have written this
when I left I left in 2003 so a what 16
years ago yeah so can not it took that
long time for me to get some distance
because I had to realize all the things
that I did not just at Netflix but at
the previous companies yeah
what were the ones that were look just
hash dances was it worked
cuz this is really this is a really
interesting question I believe that I
talk a lot about creating clarity of the
fact that I owned nothing of Wine
Library because I thought it was
important to help the audience but but
there is an absolute truth to the fact
that there was a certain time in my
career that I didn't want to create that
clarity because there was a level of you
know that's who I was you know like I
was a owner of Wine Library like I
didn't want to give up that truth
because otherwise I have nothing because
I restarted right right if I'm being
fair with myself I you know I didn't
create as much clarity of me owning
nothing and building it for my parents
now it's this noble
act but for three or four years there
were I didn't create clarity I needed it
I had my own level of insecurity even
though I'm never that insecure yeah let
me ask you a question I apologized oh
sure but I want to ask you a very deep
question for me how are you dealing with
you know it's been 60 you know I love I
think I'm only even asking you this
question because of the vibe you gave me
by saying it's been 16 years it must be
very tricky to be the co-founder and
first CEO of Netflix in a world where it
is the company that it is now which is a
very different you know iteration of
what it was like how do you balance the
gravitas of such a title versus your own
internal mechanism of how much or how
little and I which I have no context for
of how you feel about where it is today
being based on your DNA and execution as
an unbelievably good question because it
is something that takes took a long time
to put into context which is I don't I I
don't want to take credit for something
that's not me I believe that about you
which is why I even felt the courage to
ask you the question I just asked
writing which is why I think it's a
super important question writing the
book was fantastic
because you begin to realize what we
really did accomplish and going from 0
to 1 what Reed has done is going from 1
to 7 thousand two hundred ninety which
is also remarkable I understand
I recognize every minute that when I
travel someplace and everyone wants to
selfie with me because of Netflix yes
that's not custom me yeah so the real
thing is what do you do with the
calibrate what part of you that is
correct you kid I'm not gonna say no no
no go away I mean that's but I am saying
what do I do with that yeah that's right
I have a I can show up to speak and
it'll come to hear me and wonder what
how do I use yeah and I'll be honest
with you having it framed up in my mind
of what was gonna happen that's actually
just not true
having enough knowledge of what happened
with the company from afar it's really
interesting where my mind and heart is
going right now which is Wow
this guy has so much to [ __ ] give
because I very much you know listen this
is me paying a compliment to myself so
it's not as good of a compliment as it
sounds but like you know the reality is
when I see these similarities that we
have and I know how valuable they are to
be a conversation you know all of a
sudden it's like put me in this happy
plate and it's actually where I actually
asked you that question because I
actually think it's the Kryptonite
potentially - all the good you can do
over the next three decades I think and
just hearing you answer it and even the
zero to one want to like I'm happy right
now because I believe you have a lot to
give based on what I'm hearing come out
of your mouth and the origin story and I
love the fact that you've been able to
calibrate this dragon because I think
the dragon could have been the thing
that unwound you do you know this cuz
you're doing the reverse event you
[ __ ] run around and take credit for
[ __ ] that I mean that they're not even
remotely close to having to do with it
they happen to like stumble there's
literally people who like [ __ ]
cleaned the toilet at Netflix in week
one who claim to be the CEO yes bogus I
agree happens every day yeah and it's
absolutely what I didn't I did not want
that bit even and it's it's also saying
it's not wasn't me there's a cast
because it has the important point is a
cast even the zero to one there's a cast
of people who all contributed in the men
set and it that's what I want that's
that's what I want people to say is is
this how is this a that this is not some
guy who took us MBAs MBA and you can I
give you a huge recommendation of course
I highly recommend you putting out some
more content around this on LinkedIn at
scale I think you can really help people
my best don't have the luxury of you and
I self-esteem and circumstances who
create association with success that has
nothing to do with it you know what it's
like it's like all those Golden State
warrior and Patriot fans that run around
that aren't from those towns who need to
wear those jerseys to think they're
successful all these [ __ ] these Patriot
fans mark that are walking around today
proud of themselves because they win for
a team that won 43 nothing yesterday are
losers yeah now you can be have pride in
your team but
you have no association to the Patriots
you're not from Boston nobody in her
family's from Boston you didn't my
favorite [ __ ] one you didn't go to
Michigan
all these [ __ ] faces from Michigan were
like well I went to Michigan and Brady
went to Michigan so I'm a patriot fan
[ __ ] you you're from Seattle dick you
know so all those people right
you know the people from New England the
people whose parents are familiar they
can get there a little bit but like
needing some association from winning to
make yourself feel like a winner is the
great vulnerability of our society yeah
that's a really astute observation I
agree
Wow and I think you you with this story
and your DNA is no joke so far I don't
know that many people but I know a lot
of stuff could have an incredible impact
on this conversation that I think leads
to a lot more happiness and a lot less
insecurity you yeah I really mean it I I
you know I'm I'm I'm being selfish about
an ambition towards happiness a lot of
people try to associate themselves with
winning that they deep down know they
had nothing to do with it yes it's it's
an honesty and a vulnerability and you
got to be able to do that for yourself
before you can do it for anybody what do
you live I live in Santa Cruz California
which is beautiful so uh I've got a
pretty I've got it great now I do get it
I get you know I don't do it I have a
slightly different model because I work
with this very small number of people
very you know doing mentoring early
startup selling shares of Netflix did I
like how did you play your selling of
shares not to not to go too deep into
your like no an example let me let me
tell you how why I'm asking because I
think it could teach people something
look uh I never sold a share Facebook I
was a very early investor right and I
never sold a share and it blows my mind
that I now have more money than a lot of
early Facebook employees who sold at $19
a share because they just wanted the
quick liquid I've never been in a
position like you have I'm always
fascinated by executives that are part
of these kind of long tail winds like by
selling one share you're leaving money
on the table and I'm always fascinated
how people play it not to I don't want
you to go too deep because I don't like
to pry how did you think about it
strategically along the way exactly the
opposite of you please oh I my attitude
nobody knows anything fair I mean no you
you were lucky with Facebook why you
know might happen you might have owned
shares a yahoo and if you tell me I
could tell the difference we noticed but
my guys see that I never see that if my
head Yahoo he does lost all your money
yours I have more empathy for because
there was such a substantial business
model shift yeah yeah no I was
flabbergasted and here and this is where
I can say I wasn't lucky because you
could see videos of me as fat Gary
during that time yelling yelling at
people that Facebook hasn't even started
yelling yeah yelling yours is different
because it was such a gigantic switch of
a business model yeah it's true but that
you know I have always had faith in our
ability to do those things we talked
about earlier which has always the past
behind evolved and recognized and we did
it many times I have a whole bunch of
examples when we did that
I knew this company would do that but
still I sold shares continuously that I
understand I think the question you know
the question is did you go by the book
and do what a lot of executive like
continuously or you were you weren't
allowed to do that back when I was a lad
because then if you were first of all we
had the IPO yeah and I had had some
reasonable successes you know yes
magazine as we saw on the other
companies and stuff so but this was a
different order of magnitude yes and we
freaking out
yeah of course let's for ya I'm worried
like I can't wait to six months to sell
like like the unlock know okay the diff
some part of you yes but not not for
that reason I was going I need to this
is so different I can't gamble my
family's yeah legacy sitting I respect
because of that and so it actually was
what there was two reasons I left
Netflix and one was recognizing I'm not
it's too big of a company now for you
I'm not good I'm not good at it the
other one by the way real quick I
apologize I will never be the CEO of a
public company
I won't I can't very I'll be terrible at
it yeah no no really bad like I get on a
[ __ ] like like what do they call like
a recordings call like the first
question like the first questions like
Gary why did manor have a bad December
big [ __ ] you [ __ ]
what do you mean you're
you're [ __ ] student on Wall Street
this is real [ __ ] because I think in 40
years this voice is gonna be big so I
[ __ ] hurt my P&L because I'm an
investing I I'm totally with you yeah I
say was like Vaynerchuk arse is out
[ __ ] Goldman Sachs should be off the
board like I'll be [ __ ] I'd be fired
within 43 seconds I have a reminder
reading folder which I look at every
month or two with things in there I want
to remember and one of them is a Jeff
Bezos letter right when they went public
saying basically don't buy this stock if
you are looking for the stock to go up
because I am NOT that's a promise
running it so I totally agree the
counter to why I think I do want to go
public but anyway like do not buy a
single share for next decade and I want
to rise like a phoenix and kill all of
you anyway so my theory is this let's do
a couple things
yes sir knowing that I want everybody
who's listening right now to buy this
book who do you think this helps the
most and the books out now yes so
tomorrow time we air tomorrow for
watching up pre-order absolutely so I'm
gonna take what you've got telling you
slightly circuitous route by saying that
you've everyone has heard that advice
fall your dreams yes no everyone has
this idea they wake up doesn't need to
be a business there could be something
they want to start something they want
to try the way they want to parent
absolutely really hot on this like
there's a lot of stay-at-home parents
because I've been getting more into this
space who's like you gave me the courage
to home-school you gave me the courage
to take my kid out of La Crosse he's the
only kid not in La Crosse in this high
net worth you know town and it excites
me I'm like wait a minute this is as
much like entrepreneurship as I thought
it was have courage to do what you know
is right this that's who I think
benefits most anybody who has these
ideas and they're going I want to do
something but I but I go on the blank
and I'm going this is the ghetto stop
the butter I crap
but it's not just here's this step one
step two it shows how that thinking
works in building something for real how
come
are you in your own mind with your own
self about the success of this book
oh I'm my competitive [ __ ] like
you're like looking at the rankings
every minute oh yeah you're totally
sucked into pretty not because this is
for the game of it yeah the game of it I
don't really it's not gonna change not
the economics everything [ __ ]
economics everything I do I want to do
really well I understand and you have a
friend who's like a good friend who like
you have this like fun like your eat
maybe she or he doesn't even know this
but you have this weird like I want to
sell you do right I [ __ ] knew it
other people who've written books and
I'm like in there looking at the numbers
and going [ __ ] I'm 6,000 and they're
like 3,000 ok so but again it's it's
because first of all I'd never pushed a
book before ok and I'm going part of it
is how cool is it writing the book the
structures learning about that the other
thing is what how do you learn how to
sell a book well this is for my awesome
publisher you know at Harper little
brown like I'm gonna make a very simple
blanket statement quickly neck how the
advice of my counsel I'm gonna take the
fifth on this one because you don't know
you know no yeah yeah I mean I but it's
like I go why is the hardcover coming
out before the paperback I don't is that
good for the Mari this is not because I
completely run well over this is because
I don't want to have this conversation
because I'm gonna jump out the window
goes on in publishing that makes any
[ __ ] sense for 2003
especially when the framework is the one
that you and I have yeah there is some
irony I grew this business which
overturned this whole established way of
doing sequencing movies and now I'm well
you know what book form people make fun
of me a lot of times like Gary you [ __ ]
on all this stuff why do you write books
I'm like cuz people read them yeah I
don't impose my way of learning on the
world
and I understand that a lot of people
learn in this format by their desk at
night for nights bang through it on
vacation like I have no passion it's why
I put out content on every platform
right I don't care if you want to listen
to this podcast I don't care if you're
watching live right now on LinkedIn I
don't care if one of the cool snippets I
want that selling I don't sell like you
know like you know if that becomes the
gateway like I don't get to judge how
one learns yeah all right pretty cool
thanks for being on my pleasure it's
really awesome
thank you pick up the book guys I have a
funny feeling it's gonna bring value
thanks